[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le grand prix de pau aura été cette
année un marché de dupes pour tous les
favoris pilotes et constructeurs y
compris on attendait la victoire du
champion du monde jack brabham au volant
de sa cooper au bout de 20 km jack
brabham et tous les autres races de
l'automobile n'était déjà plus dans la
course s'il avait suivi ce conseil
leur voiture aurait peut-être tenu
jusqu'au bout les pilotes ne sont pas
très en forme et les voitures pas tout à
fait au point g qui fait un tête à queue
en sait quelque chose
peut-être un signe en numéro 4 victime
d'une cascade d'incidents il n'ira pas
loin
pas plus le belge sein de biens numéro
c'est en définitive un jeune écossais de
25 ans tim clark
au volant de sa lotus numéro 6 qui
remporte le grand prix de pau à plus de
102 de moyenne lorsque débute le match
france espagne à madrid devant 80000
spectateurs on se demande si les joueurs
français maillot foncé culotte blanche
ne court pas à la catastrophe
les espagnols sont en effet archi favori
de la rencontre dès les premières
minutes de jeu les français ne font pas
tellement mauvaise figure la catastrophe
ce n'est pas pour ses prouesses
les espagnols sont lents mal inspiré
hormis trento numéro 11 qui s'aiment de
temps à autre le désarroi dans la
défense française
pas de chance l'équipe de france a
besoin d'une demi heure de jeu copains
et hors de combat contre l'espagne à
proximité des bus belle balle de cuba
l'a bien reprise de la tête par santana
1 0 pour l'espagne c'est très flatteur
pour les espagnols pas très convaincant
et très honorable somme toute pour les
français très courageux dans l'ensemble
seulement voilà le courage n'est pas
suffisant pour marquer des buts des
occasions les français en ont en
deuxième mi-temps surtout ils ne savent
pas en tirer partie en revanche les
espagnols dominent et parfois
techniquement sont beaucoup plus
réalistes comme benneteau qui marque un
second but pour l'espagne qui va la
france par 2 à 0
et
malgré les sourires compte échanger à
washington le président kennedy et
monsieur gromyko au cours d'une entrevue
qui a fait quelques bruits l'inquiétude
suscitée par la sphère laotienne reste
au premier plan des soucis
internationaux le prince souverain à
foum à qui s'est entretenu à paris avec
monsieur michel debré et les
responsables français
parviendra-t-il à faire triompher sa
thèse chef du gouvernement renversé par
le général phung me il espère convaincre
le monde de la nécessité d'une politique
de neutralité au laos
[Musique]
le pâle visage de lister leurs sortant
de sa clinique londonienne aux côtés de
son mari eddie fisher aura été plus apte
que le lointain la hausse a passionné
les foules
l' enthousiasme de ses admirateurs de
londres en est le témoignage
le salut de new york ne le fut pas moins
son arrivée et des choeurs innombrables
dans le vaste monde
or ont repris leur rythme normal à la
nouvelle que la belle vedette par ai
passé quatre mois de convalescence en
californie
la gloire et plus rebelles sans doute
pour les inventeurs quand même ils
auraient dut génie
quel touriste aurait l'idée en passant à
liège en belgique de rendre visite à
l'horloger louis zimmer qui donnait
pourtant voici 30 ans à la cité flamande
son plus beau fleuron latour zimmer qui
renferme une étonnante horloge
astronomique presque adrien dit qu'avec
l'heure de greenwich leur démarrer la
saison le jour le mois leur la semaine
le cycle solaire le signe du zodiaque
l'équation du temps le cycle lunaire et
les phases de la lune
à midi des personnages apparaissent à
une fenêtre
les trois premiers roi de belgique ne
faut-il pas admirer l'esprit qui a
engendré un pareil mécanisme lequel
anime aussi un planétarium et trois
panneaux entier de cadran astronomiques
sans oublier le personnage qui en ce
faisant nous apprend les changements de
poids qui nous attend sur les autres
planètes
[Musique]
l'europe tentent de s'unir à strasbourg
17 nations continue la discussion mais
jusqu'ici on a pu créer que deux europe
celle des 7 et celle des six lors des
six a pris corps avec le traité de rome
depuis on s'efforce de compléter cet
édifice qui appauvrit géographique un
bloc continental compact inscrits dans
la géographie la tentation à l'unité
mais aussi dans l'économie l'europe des
six groupes et dans le marché commun
dispose en effet de possibilités
agricole variés et complémentaires
oh
[Musique]
elle dispose aussi d'un potentiel
industriel considérable puisqu'il est
trois fois supérieur à celui de l'autre
europe celle des cèpes
s'y ajoutent enfin un facteur historique
le souvenir de l' empire de charlemagne
[Musique]
les barrières douanières et les poteaux
frontières apparaissent dans ces
conditions comme des obstacles assez
mince à la réalisation d'une unité
économique voire d'une unité politique
qui n'est pas sans avoir déjà des
partisans résolus
[Musique]
tout autre nom se présente les sept
nations dispersés sur la carte en
majorité maritime et dont l'économie
repose essentiellement sur les échanges
au nord comme au sud ces pays ont une
solide tradition de commerçants au long
cours peuple de marins dont l'histoire
fourmille de découvreur de terres
lointaines les vasco de gama aider
christophe colomb
ses caractéristiques ses capitales sont
des ports comme lisbonne comme londres
comme stockholm
c'est aussi le cas d'oslo et de
copenhague
[Musique]
mais la suisse direz vous c'est que son
économie fait aussi d'échanger de
spéculation s'assimile parfaitement à
celle des nations maritimes
mais l'autriche son cas est particulier
le traité de paix en a fait un pays
auquel une association européenne aussi
précise que celle des six est interdite
les réalités font que l'europe des six
est une tentation pour l'europe entière
la grèce vient d'y faire son entrée
malgré les sollicitations du groupe des
sept conduit par l'angleterre
l'angleterre n'est elle même pas
insensible à l'après des 6 et multiplie
ses sourires au point qu'on a pu dire
qu'elles rôdent autour du marché commun
[Musique]
et l'on comprend très bien cette
tentation pour des peuples de marchands
lorsqu'on imagine que les six forme d'un
marché de 180 millions de clients et
c'est peut-être pourquoi un jour
l'europe des six et l'europe 17
s'uniront pour faire l'europe tout court
[Musique]
c'est vers une turquie inconnu que
conduit ce pont romain jeter voici vingt
siècles sur un affluent du hot flat
infiniment rares en effet sont ceux qui
comme jean jacques fleury et pierre
birot les auteurs de ces images ont
voulu atteindre au sommet de la montagne
de nems road derniers contreforts du
taurus le tumulus antiochus au pied de
l'énorme amas de cailloutis
d'impressionnants figure de pierre
démantelé par le temps va y sur le
tombeau d'un caucus premier roi de comme
à gênes prince peu connu qui régnait au
1er siècle avant jésus-christ sur l'un
des pays les plus ignorés aujourd'hui
des tremblements de terre successifs ont
précipité au sol c'était de dieu dont
les hautes silhouettes sculptées dans le
rock domine l entrée du tombeau
souterrain de leurs huit mètres de
hauteur
seul debout aujourd'hui la déesse de la
vie et de la fécondité continue intacte
cette veille deux fois millénaire
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]